DAN: Hi.
CHRIS: Hi, Dan.
DAN: Hi, Chris.
CHRIS: So, uh--
DAN: Oh, OK.
CHRIS: Every pore,
every single pore.
DAN: It's amazing.
CHRIS: Yeah, hi everybody.
I'm Chris Debona.
But you're not
really here for me.
You're here for our
friend Dan Lyons.
So say hi.
DAN: Hi, that's
terrifying, thank you.
And thank you for coming.
And I don't know if we'll
have-- can we do questions?
Or not really, right?
We'll just-- we'll talk.
CHRIS: Yeah, yeah we'll talk.
DAN: Yeah, yeah, OK.
I did a talk at Google
Cambridge recently.
It was really, really
fun-- really good.
It was full of-- I learned
a new word-- "Greyglers."
CHRIS: Greyglers, yes.
DAN: Which is what--
the people who
are working at Google who are
over a certain age, lets say.
Either they call themselves
Greyglers or people call
them that behind their back.
I don't know.
But--
CHRIS: No, no they've been
calling themselves that as long
as I've been here so--
DAN: Yeah?
CHRIS: Yeah, I
mean like 12 years.
DAN: And it was a
lot of Greyglers.
Because my book is sort of
about being old and trying
to work in tech and in a
startup with young people.
So I had all these old Google
people-- it skewed very old.
And it was really-- not very
old, I mean like, you know, 40.
Yeah, there's a
guy with gray hair.
See look at him he's
like a Greygler.
And it was great.
It was really, really fun.
It was really, really cool,
interesting group of people.
Yeah.
CHRIS: You know, we don't
actually need you to like us
but it's nice that
you do, you know.
DAN: No, that's the other thing.
I forgot I had a little
spee-- I opened up
my presentation there--
so I really just
sincerely mean this.
I really love Google.
And I know people hate Google.
They think it's like
the evil empire.
And I've always
felt the other way.
And my whole life is built
around Google products.
I realized this recently.
I've been using
Android for years.
Everything on my
computer is on Chrome.
I have Google Calendar, Gmail.
Basically my whole online
life is based around Google.
And I started out-- I
should do the same here--
by just thanking all
these people because I
know it's really hard.
And I could never make
any of these things
that I use every day.
And I don't know how
you guys make them.
But seriously, Google Maps,
and Navigation, and Waze, so
my whole life, I
realized recently,
is more or less based
on-- Google Cloud,
you know the picture--
I put my photos there.
So I do sincerely feel
grateful to all of you
for everything you do.
CHRIS: I hope we continue to
earn that from you, you know.
I think I said that earlier
with the Android stuff.
DAN: For me there was a moment--
I was in Germany several years
ago, like 2012, and we were--
CHRIS: So I'm, so
I'm so resisting
making old person jokes, right?
So I'm 44, so I'm old
by your definition.
But I was like, so was this
before the wall came down or?
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry, I just got to get
it out there, but you know.
DAN: This was when
there was still
an Austro-Hungarian empire.
CHRIS: Yeah, yeah
the [INAUDIBLE].
DAN: Right before they
killed the Archduke.
CHRIS: It was fake Franco.
DAN: Fake Franc-- yeah,
that was my first alter ego.
And-- no, but we were driving
into the Munich airport.
And I had an Android phone.
I put a SIM card in
it and I remember
thinking I don't know if
this is going to work or not.
But we had a reservation at
the Holiday Inn Munich airport.
CHRIS: Which are
much nicer in Europe.
Holiday Inns are
DAN: Well, it was
still pretty cheap.
But anyway-- you know.
So we're sitting at the
airport that-- and we're
flying in the morning, so
we had booked this hotel.
At the end of our-- it was the
last night of our vacation.
And my wife said-- and
we're all stressed out,
and the kids are there, and
we have to-- and you know,
just everything's-- a rough day.
And I said-- I don't even
know where the hotel is,
I don't know where we are.
And I said hold
on, I had the phone
and I said-- navigate to
Munich airport, Holiday Inn.
And I went "da dun, da dun,
OK you're on the right road."
And I was like, oh my
god, this stuff works!
Right.
It was amazing to me.
CHRIS: Wow.
DAN: And I know
that's stupid, right.
But it was so--
CHRIS: It's not stupid.
DAN: Simple.
I remember I
thought-- and yeah, I
thought like how did a bunch of
human beings in Mountain View
make that happen.
You know, how did that-- anyway.
CHRIS: Wow, yeah.
DAN: I feel like the
unfrozen caveman.
You know, like your crazy
technology frightens
and confuses me.
CHRIS: I'm just a
simple caveman lawyer.
Yeah.
DAN: Anyway, let's
talk about-- I'm sorry.
CHRIS: You shouldn't apologize.
I mean, they're here
to listen to you talk
about random things in Europe.
DAN: Random things on vacations.
No, but thank you.
CHRIS: So congrats on
the success of the book.
I mean, you're all New
York Times best sellers.
DAN: Yeah, yeah.
CHRIS: So one of the
things I wanted to ask you,
is it bittersweet to have a very
successful book in print, when
print is a medium--
so I searched
my e-mail for the earliest
mention of Dan Lyons,
both how we first met each
other through our friend Erica.
But when I first heard of
you-- and it was actually
in a Google alert, or
the equivalent, in 1999.
I was on the PR Newswire--
DAN: Yeah.
CHRIS: --like stream.
And basically it came
down to an article
about how Forbes is retracting
a bit in their print, right?
DAN: Oh.
CHRIS: And so the
entire publication
is in a redesign slated
for a September debut,
smaller basically.
But then they say nice things
about what they're doing.
But it's a much
smaller publication,
because it's starting
to sort of wane, right?
So you write a book.
You're like, oh, I
know what I'll do.
Print's dying,
I'll write a book.
I mean, do you ever like--
does this ever hit you?
DAN: Not until just
now, actually, just now.
Thank you.
Well, I mean most of the sales
are e-books to be honest.
CHRIS: Yeah, and it's high rate.
DAN: I would say that the
vast majority are e-books
and I think-- and audiobooks.
A huge--
CHRIS: Did you
record it yourself?
Or did you have like--
DAN: Yeah, I did it myself.
No, I-- they wanted me to do
it because I have this Boston
accent and they
thought it would--
they like to have the author
do their own book apparently.
CHRIS: Yeah, no they do.
DAN: And so I spent a week in a
recording studio and I did it.
But those are most of the sales.
I think that sells way
more than print, right now.
At least on my book.
And the kind of people
who would buy this book
are probably e-book readers.
And I think in some ways it's
a better thing for authors
because it's a real impulse buy.
You can see something
hit the link and then
bam, download it to your Kindle
or your tablet or whatever.
CHRIS: Bam, download
it to your tablet
just because you've
heard of it here.
You see what I'm trying to do?
DAN: Yeah, yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
but no-- so there
is-- I think there are
a lot of impulse buys
by people with e-books.
So no, I think books are still--
it's not completely over.
I mean, but it's a
tough-- you know,
the book business is
obviously a challenge.
CHRIS: Really challenging, yeah.
Yeah, so I don't know.
How many of you
have read the book?
Just raise your hand.
DAN: Oh, my god.
CHRIS: And live streamers raise
your thumb-- whatever you do.
But you know, so it was
in fact sort of the trials
and tribulations of print that
led you to go to HubSpot, which
is the subject of the book.
DAN: Right, so in
a nutshell, it was
that I got-- I was
working-- I went
from "Forbes" to "Newsweek."
And I knew "Newsweek," even
when I joined which was 2008,
I knew OK that's-- they're not
going to be around forever.
But I really wanted to
work at a place like that
before the media business
completely blew up,
because I had very high
regard for "Newsweek"
and what they did.
And the people who
were working there
were fantastic journalists.
It was-- really, honestly,
I would pinch myself
when I would walk
in there and see
the people I was working with.
And so I got laid off.
And I thought-- not only was my
company going out of business;
my whole industry was
going out of business.
CHRIS: It was
heartbreaking, really.
DAN: It was very, very sad.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
And I have young kids, I
have twins who are now 10.
They were six or seven then.
And I thought--
CHRIS: You were about
to go on a trip that
was going to be so much fun.
DAN: We were about to
go on this big vacation.
CHRIS: To Munich.
DAN: Yeah, that trip
that I was talking about.
And I thought, I got to--
I have to do something.
I have to start a new career.
But I'm 50 years old.
And I mean, it's
not that big a leap.
You can go into
public relations--
a lot of journalists do that.
And at the time that
I was looking at this,
there was this big
trend that's still
kind of going on-- it's
kind of played out though--
where companies were
hiring journalists to build
their in-house newsroom.
So they had-- you know,
Intel, Oracle, Microsoft-- all
have little news operations.
Qualcomm has one.
And I thought, oh, I could get
in on this corporate journalism
thing and maybe start a
new career out of that.
And that should have
a 10 or 15 year run.
As it turns out, I don't
think it's really working out.
A lot of journalists who have
gone for like-- and VC firms
are big ones.
They're all hiring
their pet journalist
who then writes about the
industry in a way that
benefits their world view.
Right?
And Andreessen Horowitz is
probably the best at this.
They have this
incredible operation.
They have basically
a content factory
with podcasts, and analysts,
and the whole thing.
And they will turn out stuff
to their advantage, I guess,
right.
So it's sort of quasi-legitimate
when I thought well,
you know, there were no
other good journalism jobs.
It wasn't like--
I called "Time."
A lot of "Newsweek" people
who had left landed at "Time."
And I called them and
they were like, sorry.
CHRIS: That's like frying
pan to fire, though.
DAN: But I thought, OK.
But no.
They were like no, done.
It's like musical chairs
in the media business now.
Everybody's clinging
to their jobs.
And every year there's
fewer chairs and people
my age are just
getting spun out.
And I'd read all this
stuff about reinvention
and you can start over
and be a lifelong learner.
And I thought oh,
that's very exciting.
I'll do that.
And I always wanted to
work at a tech company
because I thought
covering tech companies,
you get very jealous of
the people you're covering.
And you think, man--
it's like being
a kid with your nose
pressed against the glass.
looking at this fantastic world.
Yeah, you go in and
you talk to them.
But you never
really find out what
it's like behind the curtain.
Because it's all
stage managed and PR.
But I thought it always
looked like so much fun.
I had friends who went
to Microsoft early on,
had a really good time.
Yeah, so I went to work
at a little company.
Instead of going to a big tech
company, I went to a little one
in Cambridge called HubSpot.
And--
CHRIS: It must have been really
close to where you were living.
I mean, that must
seem like a dream.
DAN: Right, so I
lived in Boston.
And that's the other problem is
like well, what tech company--
they're all-- we're
going to have to move.
And that was kind of
disruptive to our family.
And I like it out
here but-- you know,
anyway, I happened to get
lucky and found a place
right in my backyard.
So I thought OK, that's
a good, easy step.
And it's a younger,
smaller company
so maybe there'll be
more opportunities.
It'll be growing.
They haven't even gone
international yet.
So there's all this
growth ahead of them.
So that might be a
good place to be.
CHRIS: So was it in
your HubSpotter--
What do they call themselves?
DAN: HubSpotters.
CHRIS: Yeah, because--
DAN: They were very much
influenced by Google.
So they wanted to be HubSpot-y.
You guys talk about
being Google-y,
there's a Google-y
way of doing things.
And there's a HubSpot-y
We had those--
what do you guys--
CHRIS: Sounds like something you
need to clean off like fabric.
You know, like with one of
those Tide pens, you know?
DAN: Yeah, exactly.
It's HubSpot-y.
CHRIS: Oh, you've a
got a HubSpot on you.
DAN: Oh, you-- ha ha.
I do have one.
And then they had,
what is that thing you
guys have for-- quarterly
evaluations, right?
Or annual evaluations, the--
CHRIS: Oh, yeah, so we have
the whole 360 evaluation stuff.
DAN: No but there's--
like not KPIs or DRIs--
CHRIS: Oh, OKRs.
DAN: OKRs.
So at one point they say oh--
CHRIS: Objectives
and Key Results.
DAN: Yeah, we're going to
have OKRs just like Google.
But they didn't really
know how to do it.
But they were like, well, Google
does it so it must be good.
Let's try doing that.
CHRIS: And, you know, we got
it from someone out of Intel.
DAN: Yeah, it was
John Doran, right?
Wasn't it John Doran.
CHRIS: It was John-- it was
one of those guys, yeah.
But he put it across the
valley and everywhere he
invested time.
DAN: So we tried it-- yeah,
we tried all this stuff.
So that was really
cool and foreign to me,
but it was interesting
to learn about it.
And so yeah, that was the idea.
CHRIS: So you're in
this thing-- and you
said this in the book-- you
said look around the room.
A year from now a lot
of the people around you
won't be here anymore.
Did they really
go down this road?
DAN: Oh, yeah it was
a lot of brainwashing.
So it was very cult-y.
And so, you know, journalists
tend to be very cynical.
And it's-- the culture from one
newsroom to another sort of is
the same.
You know, if you
meet journalists
from wherever they are, they
generally all kind of-- it's
a tribe.
CHRIS: They like drinking
the brown water, you know--
DAN: Yeah, yeah--
CHRIS: Whiskey, whiskey.
DAN: They're all
negative and cynical.
And I was thinking I couldn't
get used to it at HubSpot.
Everybody was so
positive and so upbeat.
And at one point
in a meeting I was
like, you guys are all so
cheery, I just can't stand it.
And they were like,
well, would you rather
be with negative, angry people?
I was like, yes, dude.
That's what--I've spent my
whole life with negative,
angry people.
CHRIS: The whole world is like--
DAN: Negative,
angry people, yes!
So it is very
relentlessly upbeat.
But we had training.
And the training was
supposedly to learn
how to use the product.
But it really was
like you don't know
how special you are to be here.
Thousands of people competed
to get this job that you have.
It's harder to get in here
than to get into Harvard.
That's how exclusive it is here.
Now, they're all
right out of college,
and they're young kids.
And they're all, you know,
freshly scrubbed and they're
like, OK, I'm going to do it.
And they're like, but
this is only half.
The next step is whether
you can make it here.
And half these people aren't
going to be here in a year.
That's how hard it is.
And I'm just old.
We went around and they
said you have to talk
about what makes you special.
Let's all introduce ourselves.
CHRIS: What's your superpower?
DAN: Well, what's
your superpower.
And they'd talk about
having superpowers and being
rock stars and engaging
in "delightion" which
meant delighting customers.
CHRIS: So that's how
you pronounce it?
De-lie-shun.
DAN: Delightion--
CHRIS: I didn't [INAUDIBLE]
DAN: It's delight
turned into a noun.
Delight is already a noun.
Delight is a noun but then
they made another noun--
delightion-- which is the
process of delivering delight
to people.
CHRIS: Is that a gerund?
DAN: No, I don't
think it's a gerund.
Anyway, so they went
around and they're
like, what makes
you special, unique.
And I'm like I don't know.
I'm the only one in the room
that's had a colonoscopy.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
CHRIS: I know what
my PSA level is.
DAN: I have-- I have
high cholesterol.
I have to take a
statin every day.
I take Lipitor.
You know, because
they're all like,
you know, people don't know
this, but I play guitar.
So I was like, oh, great.
You know, but-- so it's like--
CHRIS: I own a Corgi.
DAN: Yeah, the main guy, the
training guy, his thing was he
played in a rock
band, a heavy metal--
a hair metal cover
band on weekends.
It was like, oh, cool.
But then the company would
hire his band for every event.
I think they got them for free.
So we had the same hair metal
band at every corporate event
playing the same songs.
[LAUGHTER]
And it--
CHRIS: Was it mostly
Duran Duran covers?
DAN: Oh yeah, it was awful.
It was just really bad.
But he's a nice guy.
So he's probably going to
watch this now and hate me.
But-- so yeah, so
it was like that.
CHRIS: The world is filled
with nice people, I mean--
DAN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
CHRIS: No-- no
matter where you go.
DAN: No, no,
they're nice people.
CHRIS: Mostly, somewhat.
DAN: Just very chaotic
and disorganized.
So the long story short is I did
this thing, it didn't work out.
I realized after a while, oh,
you know, I don't belong here.
And I really should just be a
journalist or do something--
and that's really
what I had to do.
And then halfway through it, I
got this, call out of the blue
to go work on "Silicon
Valley," the TV show on HBO.
And it was like going from--
you know the Steve Jobs
line about the ice
water to people in hell?
It was like that.
It was like, oh shit.
I was at the Adobe
Digital Marketing Summit
in Salt Lake City.
I was going to kill myself.
I was seriously thinking,
if you commit suicide
in like Salt Lake
City in a hotel,
in a Marriott-- I thought it's
kind of a horrible way to die.
But I'm thinking,
OK, I'll do it.
CHRIS: With a little
bottle of three-two beer.
DAN: Yeah, I've got
a bottle of Ambien.
If I took it all, I
probably could do it, right?
I mean that's a
cowardly way out, right?
You got to do it-- you know.
CHRIS: I imagine
the Marriott has
like a special elevator for
all the suicide victims.
DAN: The suicides.
Yeah, they get you off the back.
So I'm like-- I'm seriously
sitting there thinking this
is the worst moment of my life.
This is as low as my life
has ever-- six months ago,
eight months ago, I was
working at "Newsweek"
interviewing really cool people.
And now I'm here.
And I got this
call saying do you
want to work on the TV show.
Because I had developed a
show based on Fake Steve
back in 2010.
CHRIS: So "Fake Steve Jobs"-- I
don't know if you're old enough
to remember "Fake Steve Jobs."
DAN: See one guy, yeah.
So I did this "Fake
Steve Jobs" book.
CHRIS: He's like, Namaste, yeah.
DAN: People don't
know this, but I
wrote a book based on "Fake
Steve Jobs" that nobody bought.
And then-- but it got developed.
A guy from "Curb
Your Enthusiasm,"
the guy who made "Bruno"
and "Borat," Larry Charles.
He read the book and he was
like, oh, I really like this.
Let's do a TV show.
So I worked with him and
we developed and we sold it
to a cable network called Epix.
We wrote all these episodes
and then it never got shot
and it kind of all
just died away.
But then the "Silicon
Valley" guys--
the main writer on "Silicon
Valley" was also on "Curb"
and those two guys
know each other.
So when that show
got picked up--
CHRIS: This Alec Berg?
DAN: Alec Berg.
So Alec Berg-- and I
had meetings with him
about Fake Steve that
never worked out.
So he said oh,
come out and work--
do you want to come out
and work on season two.
So I worked on
season two and then
on season three, which is
the one that's airing now.
I did go back to HubSpot briefly
after season two, but just
for a couple months.
It didn't-- it really
went downhill fast.
But I had always
wanted to see this.
You know, the
story people tell--
every friend of mine who
works in corporate America
has a story of, either
they did this to someone
or had it done to
them or both, where
the company doesn't
want you anymore,
but they can't fire you.
Or for whatever
reason they figure
they can't fire you so they
have to just make you miserable
so you'll leave.
Just make your life worse, and
worse, and worse, and worse
till finally you just go, right?
And they started
doing that to me.
And I was like, this
is awesome, right.
This is so cool.
I had this crazy
boss who had been
a really good friend
of mine but clearly had
got the message,
no, he's got to go.
And I was like-- every day
I would come in thinking,
what is he going to do today?
This is so amazing.
Like what crazy--
CHRIS: Is this when he
started bringing Molly
into the conversation.
DAN: Oh, no, no
that was earlier.
CHRIS: Was that earlier?
DAN: Yeah, that was the moment
when I knew I didn't fit in.
So a few months in I
had-- we got a message
that the co-founder,
the CTO, had written
this big article about
management for Linked--
you know, he's a
LinkedIn Influencer.
And um-- oh yeah, this
is our-- this is our--
CHRIS: We're not really
going to take questions
from the audience but--
DAN: The gopher.
CHRIS: This is the Go Gopher.
I'm sure you're
familiar with him.
DAN: You can find this article.
If you look up
online Dharmesh Shah,
and the headline
is "Your Customers
Are Not Selfish Ignorant Control
Freaks," something like that.
CHRIS: That's what
leadership is for.
DAN: And his point was
that he had come up
with this great breakthrough,
which was that you should
bring a teddy bear to meetings.
He was bringing a
teddy bear to meetings.
And the teddy bear
would sit in a chair
and it would be a
stand-in for the customer,
so that in the meeting
you would always
be thinking of the customer.
You'd always be solving
for the customer
by having the teddy bear there.
CHRIS: I'd like you to
address the gopher when
you talk about this.
DAN: Because he's the customer.
CHRIS: This is our--
DAN: And he had a
picture, he had--
CHRIS: Delightion.
DAN: A real picture, of a real
meeting, with the teddy bear
sitting next to our CMO.
CHRIS: It's the funniest
shit you've ever seen.
DAN: Drinking a Red Bull.
There's a little Red Bull
in front of the teddy bear.
The Red Bull looks
really-- I mean,
the teddy bear looks
really pissed off.
And her name was Molly.
CHRIS: The teddy
bear was named Molly,
and she was a
single mother from--
DAN: Well, they
had buyer personas.
So we had Mary Marketer
and we had Olly Owner,
who's a small business owner.
So they combined it and
made Molly the teddy bear.
So I worked with a guy-- my
boss-- who was a young guy.
We sat screen to screen
at a table, at a desk.
And he was pretty cool.
He once wanted to
be a journalist.
He was pretty cynic-- he
thought he was pretty cynical.
And so this article came out.
And I leaned around his
screen and I was like dude,
did you read that article?
And he was like, oh--
yeah, yeah, it was good.
And I was like no, no--
the teddy bear thing.
Did you read the
teddy bear thing?
And he's like, yeah.
And I'm like, OK,
that's crazy, right?
That's freaking nuts, right?
And he's like, well, you
know, these startups are kind
of-- they're kind of eccentric.
I was like, no, no, no, come on.
That's fucking crazy to bring a
teddy bear to meetings, right?
And he was just
not going to agree.
This guy had worked
at Google, right?
Early on, right out of school.
So I said to him,
are you telling me
when you were at Google, if
Larry or Sergey announced
that they were bringing
a teddy bear to meetings,
and it was going to stand
in for the customer,
and you were all going
to take it seriously,
nobody would make fun of that?
Nobody would mock that?
Because I think they would
put him in a asylum, right.
He's like, well, you know,
startups are different.
But that's when I knew, OK,
I've got to get out of here.
I called a friend of mine
who'd been a journalist who
went into marketing.
And said, is this normal?
CHRIS: It's normal.
DAN: The teddy bear thing.
It wasn't that the
teddy bear was crazy.
It was that nobody would
laugh at the teddy bear.
That's what got to me.
In any newsroom there are
people-- there's occasionally
some crazy managing editor who
might do something like that.
But everyone would go
out and buy a teddy bear,
and put bondage gear on
it, or hang it from nooses.
You know, we'd do
terrible things.
We'd sodomize the teddy bears.
You know, we'd just do
terrible things to teddy bears
to mock the guy.
But nobody did that.
Everybody was just like, mm.
CHRIS: Yeah!
DAN: This is awesome!
Teddy bears!
CHRIS: Let's win one for Molly.
DAN: And when my book
came out, the company
published a response to
some things, more or less.
The other thing they had
was when they fired people,
they called it graduation,
which I thought was crazy.
And they would say-- we'd
get this email saying,
hey everybody, you
know, just want
to let you know that
Derek has graduated
and he's going to go off.
And we're so excited
to see what he's
going to do with his superpowers
on his next big rock star
adventure.
And I was like, you
fired that guy, right?
You fired his ass.
CHRIS: Like a ninja, he's
gone stealthy into the night.
DAN: Yeah, he's going to
take his ninja superpowers.
They would say-- literally
those were the words.
Those are real words.
And you'd look over and
the guy's desk is empty.
He's just gone.
He's just vanished.
He just disappeared.
And you never knew
he was leaving.
My first week there I
had lunch with a woman,
young woman right
out of college,
who wanted to write a book.
She's like, you wrote a book.
Can you talk to me
about writing a book?
Yes.
We go have lunch.
She's really great.
She had these great ideas
about millennials and marketing
to millennials.
Great, we talked about it.
And that night,
we get an e-mail.
I forget it-- I don't
want to say her name.
But anyway, you know,
so-and-so has graduated
and we're so excited.
She's leaving the
company and she's
moving on to the next thing.
And so I called her--
or I emailed her--
I said, how come you didn't
even mention this at lunch.
She's like, I didn't even know.
She said I just got a call
saying you graduated, bye.
Don't come back tomorrow.
That's it.
See you later.
And after my book
came out, someone
wrote to me saying--
first job out of college,
she got hired to work in HR.
Her life dream was
to work in HR which--
CHRIS: There are
people out there--
DAN: Not judging.
CHRIS: They're very nice.
No, seriously a good HR
person, man-- awesome.
DAN: Yeah, no, right.
And she had all
these big ideas she's
bringing-- three months in
they called her into a meeting
and said, you know what?
You just don't seem
excited enough.
You're gone.
Take your stuff and go.
CHRIS: Where's your delightion?
DAN: Yeah, where's
your delightion.
Don't even take your
stuff, they said to her.
We'll pack your stuff
and mail it to you.
Just leave this
meeting right now.
Walk out, and go to your
car, and never come back.
Three months in.
And then they called
her the next day
and said, uh, we didn't realize
you have a lot of stuff.
You have to come in
yourself and get it.
It's too much to mail.
CHRIS: It's really heavy.
DAN: And they had her come
in and do this walk of shame
with a box and fill it up
and then leave, you know.
So it's just crazy.
And I called this
friend of mine who
had been at a bunch
of big companies,
like Cisco and stuff, and
then had gone to a startup.
And he'd done really
well at the startup.
And he said to me, look,
this is the secret--
the little secret of
startups that nobody knows
is that they're all like this.
They're all out of control,
there's no management,
nobody knows what
the F they're doing.
CHRIS: And they don't
have any processes--
DAN: Yeah, there's
no management.
CHRIS: And it's like
25-year-olds who are like,
wait, I have a staff
of how many people
I have to-- whats a budget?
What's a PNL?
DAN: Yeah, yeah.
So he's like, this is normal.
Just go with it.
And I was like, OK.
And then I was going to leave,
and somebody else said to me,
you've really-- you're a comedy
writer, you're a satirist,
and you've stumbled
into this pot of gold.
This is amazing, funny stuff.
So I realized I
was so wrapped up
in why the job wasn't
working out that I never saw,
like, oh my god, this
is really good stuff.
CHRIS: It's a goldmine.
DAN: Yeah, for comedy.
And then I started realizing,
oh, there was actually even
a bigger story about,
I think diversity,
and about what culture fit.
I think culture fit
is an insidious thing.
I came to think that
it's actually a code
word for lack of diversity.
But if we celebrate it and
call it something good,
it sounds great to
have a bunch of just
white guys in their 20s.
You know what I mean?
CHRIS: We used to
talk about Googliness
of incoming candidates.
And I got tired of it.
I was like, no one actually
knows what this means.
It's just bullshit.
DAN: Oh, really?
CHRIS: In some ways.
I mean, in the
context of hiring.
Because it's just a way for
people to hire people who are
like them.
DAN: Right.
CHRIS: It's like,
how about you find
me somebody who you think is
the exact opposite of "Googley"
or the exact opposite
of what you are.
Within the realm of engineering.
So it's like-- yeah, I mean,
it's these terms that they
throw around so lightly.
And we all chuckle
and think it's funny.
But in the end it's like-- it's
people's lives your talking
about, you know.
DAN: Yeah.
CHRIS: And so much of our
lives are spent at work.
And it's like, we want a
wonderful place to work.
But not at the cost
of our humanity.
So I don't-- I don't
want to go off--
DAN: No, no I agree.
And I think, you know,
they said that when
I first met some of these guys.
They said the line that you
hear a lot in Silicon Valley,
with startups,
anyway, was like, we
like to hire people that
I'd like to go for a beer
with after work.
Right?
And I think that's a terrible
reason to hire someone.
CHRIS: Or finger
paint with them.
DAN: Yeah, we did
finger painting.
We had a thing called
fearless Friday.
We got this email one day.
You want me to tell the story.
So saying OK, someone--
one of the people on staff
had read Sheryl Sandberg's book.
And there's something in
there about-- her advice
was do what you would do
if you weren't afraid.
Like you know--
CHRIS: Which is decent advice.
DAN: It's good advice.
So next-- two weeks
from now on Friday
it's going to be
fearless Friday.
We're going to all stop
work for the whole day.
That was the other thing.
They had the whole Google
idea of the 20% off.
Which Google doesn't
do anymore, right?
CHRIS: No, no, we do it.
But it's, honestly, for most
people this means 120% of time.
DAN: Oh, yeah.
CHRIS: So actually I did the
math early on in my career--
it was, like, 2007--
where I added up
all the Tech Talks
that you could go to,
and the 20% time,
and all the rest.
And you end up working
about 14 hours a week
if you take all the breaks
and all the lunches.
DAN: Sounds great.
CHRIS: And I'm
like, you know, that
doesn't sound like it's real.
You know.
DAN: So it doesn't really--
CHRIS: No, so, obviously people
don't go to every Tech Talk.
Not everyone does 20%
time, or even, I'd
say, single percentage points.
But that's OK.
I mean, it's there for them.
But reality is our jobs
are there for us, too.
I'm a big believer in doing the
job that you were hired to do.
I mean, we talked about this
earlier and the honor of that.
So when things like
fearless Friday come up,
what do you think?
You're like, wait, you want me
to come to work and not work?
DAN: Right, we have to
do-- the only rule was--
CHRIS: And in the
newsroom, they're
like where is the article,
this is the deadline, produce,
right?
DAN: Unfortunately,
now in newsrooms
it's also become like
you've got to hit numbers.
You've got to get clicks,
drive [? pagers ?]
and you're rewarded
based on that.
So that's part of the
reason that this coverage
of tech and everything
else has become so bad.
And I think--
CHRIS: That's
[? fan fiction, ?] you know?
DAN: Well, it's
just that if you're
working for a tech blog, or
the "New York Times," whatever,
if you cover Apple and
you're very pro-Apple so you
get a little bit of access.
You're going to
get [? pay juice ?]
because you're going to get--
people will read your articles
and they'll love it.
It's like the easiest-- that's
why "Fake Steve" took off.
It wasn't because I was
writing anything good.
It was just that there's
such a huge Apple base.
And I realized,
oh god-- and I've
seen reporters tap into that.
If you tap in and become like
the Apple fanboy reporter--
CHRIS: It's very appealing.
Because those numbers go up and
you're like, look, I'm popular
and it fills you with
that warm feeling.
DAN: Not only that, you're
getting bonused at work.
CHRIS: And getting
money is nice too.
DAN: You're straight up
bonused based on your traffic.
I mean-- and if you're
not getting traffic
you're going to get fired.
Like it's-- the way
to get traffic--
like if you're stuck covering
Enterprise, you know.
I mean, it's important
stuff to cover but it
doesn't drive page views.
So you end up having to
do 10 articles a day.
You're just trying to
win with volume, right.
So then you can't do
any real reporting.
You can't do any kind
of real journalism.
You're just aggregating
other stories
and putting some top spin on it.
And maybe trying to be--
you can try to get attention
by being outrageous.
You see the bloggers
who are really combative
and love to pick fights.
So you get all this--
it's just entertainment.
And that's, I mean, that's
actually a very serious problem
in the media business.
And I don't know
how it gets fixed.
Because unless people stop
measuring and rewarding
people on traffic,
on numbers, it's
going to be very hard to--
it's a race to the bottom.
It just becomes a
complete-- yeah.
CHRIS: I mean, do you think
we've hit a bottom yet?
I mean, it seems like they
keep on trying, you know.
DAN: Well, Donald Trump is
the Republican candidate
for president.
So I don't know.
I think we're still heading--
CHRIS: I assure you
my fingers are long.
DAN: Believe it
or not it's 2016.
Let's just put
this on the record.
No, I mean that happened.
Right?
That really happened.
And the media, I think,
is complicit in that.
I think there's a reason for
it because Trump gets ratings.
They love putting him on TV.
It's driven by--
it's the same thing.
It's clicks and views, right.
And he's the best thing that
ever happened to TV news.
And I think print journalism
didn't used to be like that.
But they've been
dragged into it now.
If you're a reporter
it's a reality.
It's part of your life.
And I'm sorry--
CHRIS: It's OK.
DAN: It's a bad-- oh god.
No, so this is why
writing books is better.
Because you can actually
go off and write a book.
You can spend a year.
You can do some reporting.
You can write what you want
to write and publish it.
And maybe you make a living.
I mean, I don't think you--
I don't think-- you know,
one in a million books you
really make a lot of money on.
But at least you can
probably make a living
and do what you want.
So that's what I found
when I was doing this.
I was like well at least I can
write what I want to write.
And it's far from perfect.
And I would rewrite-- I would
always go back and rewrite
anything and fix it.
But whatever.
You can do your work and do
something you believe in.
And maybe that's a way
out for a media person.
CHRIS: So in the
description of the book
you say look--
basically-- look what
happens when an old guy goes
to a young company, right?
DAN: Yeah.
CHRIS: And so-- if you want
to go to the next slide--
so in some ways you were
anticipating the criticism.
But in some ways,
when you said that
you sort of drove the
criticism in that direction.
I mean, you're not--
you don't present
as an especially Grandpa
Simpson sort of-- we
can switch back to
the other slide.
DAN: I actually have-- and one
of my epigraphs, I have two.
One is Dante, Dante's
"Inferno," which
is essentially a book about
a midlife crisis, right.
And then midway through
this veil of-- whatever,
I stumbled into a dark path.
Then the other quote is
from Grandpa Simpson.
Saying something like I used
to be what's it, but then
they changed what it is and
now I'm not with it-- oh yeah,
I used to be with it but then
they changed what it was.
What I'm with isn't it and
what it is I'm not with.
So I get it.
No, I felt really old.
And I never had felt old before.
But one guy at HubSpot he
used to call me grandpa.
That was like his name for me.
CHRIS: Seriously?
DAN: Yeah.
CHRIS: That's really--
DAN: Yeah, I'd
always be like, hey.
CHRIS: That guy
was kind of a jerk.
DAN: Well, yeah.
He was not, he was
not-- I don't know.
CHRIS: Sorry, scallywag.
DAN: He was a
young, young fellow.
He was-- it was OK.
But yeah, so I never felt-- I
never felt really old before.
But there's little bits
and pieces of that,
that felt like-- and that
was sort of their response,
was that people don't like.
They think, oh it's an
angry old guy ranting
about working with millennials.
And I don't have any
hatred of millennials.
I was fine.
I love-- I actually was excited
to work with young people
because I love that people
would have new ideas.
And the one big problem in the
media business where I'd been
was that you're stuck
in a legacy company that
has a legacy world, where
for better or for worse,
you have people inside
that want to change.
But it's very hard to
change an old company
and make it do
things in a new way.
It's just very, very hard.
And it's not because
they're bad people, either.
I mean, it's just that you're
encumbered with this legacy.
And I thought, you know,
maybe corporate journalism,
maybe what people
are doing there,
is going to be something--
some part of how media gets
reinvented.
I don't think where
I was specifically is
going to be part of that.
But things like BuzzFeed
are easy to sort of
dismiss as silly.
But then maybe they're doing
some good, interesting stuff.
CHRIS: Yeah, every
once in a while they'll
do an article that's
just astonishingly good
and you're like, where
did that come from.
DAN: I mean, somebody is going
to reinvent the media business.
I don't know where it's
going to come from.
And it needs a business model.
CHRIS: So when ol' media
called you, HBO says, hey.
DAN: Yeah, I respond
in a heartbeat.
CHRIS: You're like, I'm out!
TV's calling, you know.
DAN: Yeah, and TV,
mind you, I think
TV-- the TV business model
is challenged in a way--
or is about to be-- the way
the magazine business was
20 years ago.
I think they are heading
into a period of disruption
that even people-- maybe people
in Hollywood are aware of--
and I think a lot of people
who work there are not.
They're like what we
were like in the magazine
business in the late '90s.
Well, this internet thing is
coming, but, you know, yeah.
I mean, they've fought it
off for a long time, right.
They really, really fought it
off and protected their model.
But I do think that TV
business is going to change.
And it's going to change
the same way ours was.
A monopoly model that threw
off huge amounts of money
becomes a model
that now throws off
1/10 of what it
used to generate,
and then has to adjust to
a newer, lower cost base.
CHRIS: So it's
funny because if you
look at your work on "Silicon
Valley," what would you
pull out of season one, season
two, season three, where you're
like, I'm so glad I
got to tell that story
but then they stopped you.
And they said, if you keep
going and basically turn it
into reportage,
people actually won't
believe that this is happening
in the startup world.
I mean, did you ever hit that?
Because I know that when I was--
DAN: Oh because you--
you should say that.
Chris also--
CHRIS: It's about you, though.
DAN: No, no but you
consulted on the show, too.
The one thing that I think
they've done that's really,
really smart and really
cool, is they reached out
to a lot of people
in the industry.
And they actually--
they'll ask Chris,
you know, come talk
to us about blank.
And tell us this.
And explain this.
And how would this happen.
If we had a situation
where the guy wants to do,
this but then this happens would
that be at least plausible.
And guys like you would say--
CHRIS: Yeah-- no.
DAN: Eh, maybe, kind
of, not so much.
And so at least they know when
they're stretching reality
or-- keep it real.
No, but they--
CHRIS: I mean, you
must have had things
where you're like-- not even
about HubSpot but about some
of the other things
you've covered.
You would say, and
then this would happen,
and they're like no
one's going to buy that.
DAN: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely
there are things
that are so funny in reality
that are like-- yeah, if you
put it into a show, people
would think it was made up.
But there are lots of
elements of real stuff.
CHRIS: Like the
teddy bear thing.
You couldn't just bring that in.
DAN: Yeah.
CHRIS: People are like-- what?
That's contrived.
DAN: Yeah, that's
not going to work.
Yeah, but in this
year's show there
was a basically an ark where
they bring in an old guy
to be the CEO.
"An old guy."
And his ideas are he
wants to go enterprise.
He wants to put
everything in a box.
And he wants to make
money real fast.
And he explains to Richard
that the product we're making
is not the product
you think it is.
The product is the company.
The product is our stock.
And my job-- I'm brought
in here by the VCs.
My job is to take your valuation
that now is at $50 million
or $100 million, whatever it is,
and make it into $500 million
by the end of this year.
So whatever gets us to that.
That's my product.
My product is the company we're
going to sell or take public.
Whatever you're making in the
engineering department is fine.
But that's not
really the product.
And that was, I think, kind
of real but very cynical
and that made it into the show.
CHRIS: Yeah.
DAN: But there were
other things that I
think are-- I mean,
they've visited
Google a bunch of times, right?
Haven't they?
CHRIS: That's how I
ended up meeting them.
They came here and they met
a whole bunch of engineers.
DAN: You guys have been really
good about having them in.
Some companies--
early on companies
didn't want to meet them.
And then after season one,
everybody wanted to meet them.
But then they were disappointed
because it's just the writers.
The actors don't show up, right.
And it's just like--
so the writers are not
very interesting or
attractive people.
CHRIS: What do you mean?
They're all wonderful.
DAN: No, no, really nice.
But it's like
every-- people always
say to me-- I get friends in
the industry who will call me
like, hey, we want to
get TJ Miller to speak
at our conference.
I'm like, yeah,
of course you do.
They want the actors.
You know, everybody--
but the writers
are just kind of-- you
know, you've met them.
They're schlumpy guys,
who just come in--
CHRIS: He's saying that,
they're actually very--
DAN: Smart, funny guys.
But they're not like--
they're not glamorous.
CHRIS: They're-- they're
moderately attractive.
DAN: No.
I don't mean it to say
like they're not-- yeah,
I mean, you know.
Yeah.
I mean--
CHRIS: I mean, I'm not
going to say any names,
but there are a couple of
very attractive writers.
DAN: Mike Judge is
a very handsome man.
Very good looking guy, right.
CHRIS: Yes, he is.
DAN: And everybody wants to
meet him because they all
love "Beavis and Butthead."
CHRIS: If I were into
fellas, I'd take him out.
DAN: Yeah, right.
I mean, yeah, same thing.
Alec Berg, a very
good looking guy.
But as you go down the
ladder, it gets-- no,
but I just mean it's not--
I mean, they're just--
they actually look a lot like--
CHRIS: Nerds.
DAN: Nerds, yeah,
and that's the thing.
And they and they
really are nerds.
The guys who write for that
show read all the tech blogs.
And they're-- we have a--
I'm not working on the show
anymore.
But we had a slack room.
So we'd all be trading links.
And then we'd come in and
talk about this thing that
had really happened and
how could we use that.
But, yeah, no they're
really, really avidly--
and some of them never paid
any attention to tech before.
So it was kind of cool to see
them really now get into it.
CHRIS: And the craft of comedy
writing as applied to the show.
DAN: Yeah, but those guys
could turn around next year
and go write a comedy that
was set on a hockey team
and they'd go learn
everything about hockey.
They're just really smart guys.
But they really love the
field trips to Silicon Valley.
One time they had a meeting
with-- I was with them
but I didn't get to go because
only the big guys got to go.
And I'm one of the
peons on the show.
But the big guys got to have a
dinner with Reid Hoffman, Mark
Pincus, and Drew Houston,
I think, from Dropbox.
And they didn't know
who those guys were.
But like, one of the
[? CO-EPs ?] went.
He's a musician.
CHRIS: I don't know
who these guys are.
DAN: He was like-- he
was in punk rock bands.
And like he's a great writer
but he doesn't know anything
about tech.
And the next day he said to
me-- yeah, you know these guys
we met with?
I was like, who were they.
He tells me and
I'm like, no, dude,
those are really big guys.
He's like really, I don't
know, how much are they worth?
I said, I don't know, like
together-- $5 billion.
He's like what!
Yeah, that one guy,
Reid Hoffman, he's
a multibillionaire.
Then he was like, oh my god!
You know.
Actually, one day we were
walking around Google
with Matt Cutts.
CHRIS: Yeah, sure.
DAN: And one of the producer
guys who's not a writer,
said to me-- so these people
all worth a lot of money?
I'm like yeah, kind of.
He's like how about this
guy who's giving us a tour?
And I'm like oh, yeah,
he's loaded, Matt Cutts.
And-- Jesus Christ!
They all get mad.
Because they think they're
like BSDs in Hollywood
because they have $10 million.
Like, yeah, sorry.
You're at Google now, pal.
And I think that's
part of the show.
The schadenfreude-- not the
shcadenfreude-- the reverse.
The jealousy that Hollywood
has of Silicon Valley.
They're very jealous of it.
CHRIS: It's funny, you
know, because there's
this refrain that goes through
the coverage of Silicon Valley
and Hollywood, and movie
streaming, and all the piracy
stories.
And they're like, Silicon
Valley hates Hollywood,
Hollywood hates Silicon Valley.
And I'm like, have you
seen how much these nerds
like science fiction?
I mean, do you have
any clue how much
they love what comes out of
Los Angeles and Vancouver
for science fiction?
DAN: Yeah, yeah.
CHRIS: And it's like, I
mean, there's an absurd love.
It's almost like
a spurned lover.
DAN: You mean the way Silicon
Valley feels about Hollywood.
CHRIS: Both.
DAN: Oh, both.
CHRIS: Both ways.
You know, in Hollywood,
they're like I can't believe
that they're making money.
DAN: Yeah, when I was
selling the "Fake Steve Show"
and going around to
meetings and stuff
that's what I kept picking
up at every network.
To them it was like this
weird, strange world
like the Googleplex was this--
CHRIS: Alien--
DAN: Fortress, and they
really wanted to visit it.
But it was like
another planet to them.
And they were fascinated by it.
They could tell that there
was some strange culture
there that they didn't get.
And they thought it
would be worthwhile.
And I think it's
suitable to comedy
because they feel like
they're not punching down,
they're punching up.
You guys can take a joke
because at the end of the day
you're laughing all
the way to the bank.
So I think that's how they feel.
You can make fun of-- you can
make up a character like Gavin
Belson and make
fun of him because
like at the end of
the day, you know,
I don't think-- I don't think
Sergey really cares, right.
I don't think-- not that Gavin
Belson is based on Sergey.
He's certainly not.
He's more of a Larry Ellison.
I always thought he was
more a Larry Ellison.
CHRIS: Yeah, no, he's
very much Larry Ellison.
DAN: Don't you think?
Kind of Larry, yeah?
CHRIS: Yeah, because
Larry has the weird--
DAN: I never asked.
I never asked.
CHRIS: I don't need to be
called to the Oracle Trial.
DAN: Because the guys
who created the show are
no longer with the show.
And they created-- the
main characters, Gavin
and those guys,
all came from them.
So I've never been
able to find out,
who were you thinking of then
when you made that character.
But I do think they feel
like it's fair game.
You can make fun of it.
And I've been amazed the way
Silicon Valley people actually
like the show.
And they all like the humor.
Some of them say it's too much,
it's too close, it's too true.
CHRIS: No, I love it when people
tell me this-- they're like,
oh you worked on the show.
You know, this part here
I couldn't watch it.
I just had to stop.
It was too painful to watch
that mirror up to my career.
You know?
And that just makes
me feel awesome.
I'm like, yeah,
yeah, there you go.
DAN: Yeah, or there was
a storyline in season 2
where they had a
woman that got hired
and then they wanted her
and Monica to be friends,
because you're a woman
and you're a woman.
And that came from a real story.
We met a woman from
Dropbox who was
really funny and super cool.
But it was one of these things
where 10 people showed up
for the meeting.
And we all wanted
to talk to her,
but everybody else kept talking.
But she was like an engineer--
CHRIS: She's not
just from Dropbox,
she runs their engineer--
I mean, she was--
DAN: Oh, do you
know who that is?
CHRIS: Yeah, yeah, she's
a serious engineer.
She came out of the
Python-- I'm sorry,
I don't want to get all nerdy.
DAN: Her company was
acquired and that's how
she ended up at Dropbox, right?
CHRIS: Yeah.
DAN: So she had
these-- and she had
worked at really teeny-tiny
startups like Pied Piper.
So she had great stories.
And one of them was-- they
said to-- I think it was her.
I said-- maybe it
was someone else.
It was, it might have
been a woman from Google.
CHRIS: Colleen from Facebook.
DAN: No, you know,
it was a Google woman
who said look, the
worst thing-- I don't
mind being the only woman.
I've always been the
only woman, from the time
I was a computer science major.
CHRIS: [INAUDIBLE]
DAN: We came here once for
a visit-- and every meeting
was all women.
And I was like, do any
men work here at Google?
I don't know.
It was like every meeting
was just full of women.
And they were talking about
being a woman at Google.
What it's like to be
a woman at Google.
And a woman in tech.
And a woman, there's a
woman-- There's a woman.
There's an engineer
but she's a woman.
CHRIS: There's a theme
to this conversation.
DAN: She's a woman,
woman engineer.
Yeah.
So we got this message.
OK, you want to
talk about women.
But she was saying, I don't
mind being the only woman.
The worst thing is when
the second woman joins
and then they all look at you
and they want you to get along.
But I don't have any reason
to get along with her just
because we're both female.
I don't care.
I don't necessarily
want to be her friend.
And that was like-- this
woman tossed this comment out
as an aside.
But they were like oh,
that's such a good storyline.
CHRIS: Do you guys want
to share an office?
Do you want to sit
next to each other?
DAN: You should get together.
You want to go out after work?
That's like really--
CHRIS: I bet you
have a lot in common.
DAN: So that came out of a real
conversation with someone here.
Yeah, but the woman from Dropbox
too Skyped in with us later.
She was really good.
Really, really-- I think
they should have put her
in the show as a cameo.
She was really,
really compelling.
Very engaging.
CHRIS: It's really something.
But to bring it back to
the book, one of the things
that-- one of the
outcomes-- so if you
read the book, when you get to
the end, there's an epilogue.
And I don't know if you're
a skip the epilogue kind
of person, don't skip it.
Because they went nonlinear.
DAN: Yeah, we should've called
it just the next chapter rather
than the epilogue.
CHRIS: Yeah, yeah.
DAN: After the book--
after I delivered
a rough draft of the
book, they announced
that they had fired the CMO.
They were going to
fire another guy
but he resigned
before he could--
my boss, my former
boss-- and the CEO,
for doing something to try to
get hold of the manuscript.
And then-- and they turned
it over to law enforcement.
So I was like, what the f--
CHRIS: Like, Computer Fraud and
Abuse Act type investigation.
DAN: Yeah, like, Cyber Crimes.
So I end up having to get
interviewed by the FBI Cyber
Crimes guys.
And I'm like-- but they
won't tell me what happened.
I had a victim specialist.
When you're in one of these,
you get a little letter saying,
you have a victim specialist.
Here's your victim number.
I have a victim number.
Seriously.
Call in and use your victim
identification number.
CHRIS: It's probably more
secure than your social security
number.
DAN: Yeah.
But when you call-- well,
that's been compromised.
That's gone.
Everything's in the wind.
My social security
number is gone.
But-- yeah, so
they did something.
And the FBI investigated.
My victim specialist
won't tell me.
The FBI won't tell me.
So then I did a FOIA request,
a Freedom of Information Act
request.
And, unfortunately,
the book went to bed
and we couldn't get
this in the book.
But afterwards what came out
was that it was also extortion.
So somebody there came
up with this scheme--
we'll hack into his computer,
or maybe use my old company
laptop, and we'll
read his e-mail.
We'll get the book.
And then we'll
try to dig up dirt
on either me or the
publisher or somebody,
and it was an extortion scheme
to try to kill the book.
Which is like-- the
Rupert Pupkin of crime,
just like the most insane
criminal mastermind
plan of all time.
And they totally got caught.
So it was like the world's
worst-- world's worst hackers.
CHRIS: Did Molly not help them?
DAN: And until then--
right when this happened
I was starting to feel bad.
Because I wrote this
book and I was like-- ah,
I'm kind of making these
guys look like doofuses.
Maybe that's not--
CHRIS: Yeah, you don't
want to be mean or cruel.
DAN: Maybe that's unkind.
And then this happened
and I was like OK, fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Assholes.
But it was like-- seriously like
the world's worst criminals.
Like just-- so yeah.
So I still don't know.
So I got these redacted
documents from the FBI.
But you can't-- and some
of them you can fill in.
And there's more documents.
But the rest of them
I'm still trying to get.
I'm still trying to get
hold of them from the U.S.
Attorney's office.
So I don't know what's
behind-- probably not much.
But it was-- it was a
funny twist on the book.
Which is-- the book
started out to be
just a funny book
about being an old guy
and trying to deal with
kooky corporate culture.
And then has this dark twist.
And I tell you, it's weird
getting hacked and finding out
you've been hacked.
CHRIS: Oh, I know it's terrible.
DAN: I realized if you really
wanted to mess with somebody,
you don't even
have to hack them.
You just have to make them think
that maybe they've been hacked.
But you won't tell them what.
So you have to assume
that everything you own
is in the wind, right.
Like every-- your bank accounts,
everything's out there.
Kids' pictures, right.
So-- and that messes
with your head.
It makes you really paranoid.
And I was already fairly
paranoid before that.
It's just my tendency.
CHRIS: I mean, did you get
many-- during the Fake Steve
Jobs days and your
"Forbes" days,
I mean, I remember-- I
used to do a publication
and it attracted death
threats for a while.
DAN: Oh, really.
CHRIS: And so I learned really
early on in the late 90's--
DAN: That was open
source, right?
CHRIS: No, I used to work
for the State Department.
I published something called
"The Patterns of Global
Terrorism," and this was
before terrorism was cool.
DAN: Jesus-- really?
CHRIS: And so I would
get these death threats.
DAN: Oh.
CHRIS: So you learn early
on, if you're lucky,
how to manage your persona.
So we have about a minute left.
But I mean, did they
it ever get that dire.
DAN: No, no, I mean, I
had like-- who's that guy.
Oh, John Gruber at
Daring Fireball, he
used to write a lot of bad
stuff on his Apple blog
about me being a jerk.
And Paul Carr at PandoDaily
for whatever reason,
I don't know why, just hates me.
And so for a while it just
was like-- yeah, no, but--
CHRIS: And, I mean, you
know Pando's leadership
has been under this kind of
ridiculous, silly threats.
You know?
I mean--
DAN: Yeah, oh that's right.
Because they had the Uber thing.
And that was a big deal.
I actually thought
about hiring bodyguards
when my thing happened.
I wanted to go get bodyguards
and show up on CNBC
with like-- [INAUDIBLE] did.
But then-- go everywhere with
two guys with ear buds in.
Like, OK, all
right-- it's clear.
But--
CHRIS: We have a
51/40 over in upper--
DAN: Yeah, but no, no.
I never had any death threats.
I mean, even now-- I
mean, the, you know.
The book's just a funny book.
CHRIS: It's delightful.
DAN: Yeah, there's no reason
to kill me, I don't think.
Just want to put
that on the record.
CHRIS: So that's a great
place to wrap up, I think.
DAN: Yeah, I'm going
to wrap up with that.
There is no reason to kill me.
Thank you.
CHRIS: Yeah, so thank
you so much for coming.
DAN: Thank you for having me.
CHRIS: To the conference
and talking to us.
DAN: I'm happy to answer
any questions later.
But yeah.
CHRIS: Yeah, yeah.
We can go-- find
us walking around.
DAN: Oh, the gopher.
CHRIS: I can get you one.
DAN: Oh, OK.
OK, thank you.
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]